time for the press preview our first
look at the front pages
as they arrive time to see what's making
the headlines with the ft's white hall
editor sebastian payne and editor of
nottinghamshire live
natalie faye and they will be with us
right through
till midnight for our extended news
review so much more from them in just a
second first though
let's take you through the front pages
that we have
with no countries now on the green
travel list the metro declares
britain is grounded the eye encourages
readers
to holiday in the uk to ensure the final
listening of restrictions on
june the 21st can go ahead
the star reacts to the travel story by
depicting
senior members of the cabinet once again
as clowns
uh we have the uh same lead in the
mirror calling it
a foreign holiday nightmare
the express describes it as a holiday
blow for millions
uh the mail you're picking up a theme
here summer holidays have been plunged
into chaos
all as the guardian says because of
alarm over the
continuing rise of covert variants
now here's the times it reports that as
a result people are now rushing
to cancel their holidays to avoid the
chaos
and the u.s edition of the financial
times reports and concerns
over global food poverty after prices
hit
a 10-year high
we are joined tonight as you can see by
sebastian payne
and natalie fay lovely to see you both
um
and plenty to discuss so let's dive
straight on in and sebastian
let's start with them with you first on
the front
of the mirror uh brits are stuck abroad
the reason i turn to you is as an avid
follower of you on social media
i discovered you recently returned in
fact from portugal
i thought you might mention that now for
some time
yes no i i was one of the very few lucky
people who managed to make it abroad
to portugal in the very brief period it
was on
the green list for safe travel i went
out there on friday
and came back late on monday and it was
a very smooth period you know that
i did all the vigorous testing a test
before i went out a test while i was
there
and a test when i got back which came
out this morning negative
um and today's news the portugal has
come off the so-called green list onto
the ambulance which means that
leisure travel is not recommended to go
there and if you
do go then you have to quarantine at
home for 10 days afterwards
is quite sad actually because when i was
in portugal
um the restaurants were dead the hotels
were empty
the roads were deserted and they were so
delighted to see tourism because their
economy has taken
a similar pounding to the uk's from the
pandemic
and they're obviously going to be no
tourists and we're now in this situation
where
anyone who's in portugal now has to get
home before
tuesday to hit that deadline and all
those who've got breaks now i've got
dozens of friends who are planning to
go and do weekends or weeks out there
and now they face the very difficult
decision do they cancel it all and have
no holiday
or do they go out against government
guidance and from a white horde
perspective
the whole thing is a total mess it's my
understanding that last night
they thought this whole thing was going
to go ahead portuguese can stay on the
greenest in fact
more countries were going to go on the
green list and look where we are
nothing's been added to the green list
portugal's come off and i think most
brits are looking at this and waving
goodbye to any hope
of a summer holiday abroad this year
very sadly
um natalie let's just stick with the
mirror for a second do you agree with uh
sebastian's characterization of all of
this as a
as a total mess i mean i know who would
agree with that it's the travel industry
because as it says at the bottom of the
mirror on the front page there it is in
crisis as a result of all of this
yeah well i mean there's quite a few
things going on here you know there's
the uncertainty which we've already
touched on but the travel industry has
been absolutely devastated by all of
this
and the uncertainty that people are
feeling about going holidays
is you know absolutely many times over
in the travel industry
i mean just looking at it from my kind
of local point of view we've got east
midlands airport
um in the east midlands people have been
on furlough there
they've made hundreds of redundancies um
we saw that
shares in many of the airlines today
plummeted because of the uncertainty
over flights and whether people could go
abroad or not
and we've heard the chief executive of
the manchester airport group
today saying that travel is being
scapegoated and they're just being
absolutely hung out to dry
i mean what's going to happen it's just
a complete mess the traffic light system
is not fit for purpose
and we're just in the situation we're in
last year where the travel industry is
having to refund everybody
cancelled holidays uncertainty and what
people really want is our certainty so
they can book a holiday
all the uncertainty is just meaning that
people are not booking holidays and the
travel industry
is going to be absolutely devastated by
all of this
i'm sebastian i mean the front of the
the daily telegraph would
go back a story holidays and doubt
portugal goes on but i suppose
the killer detail is all around this
this this new variant which
you know as the transport secretary
suggested had
had the potential to be a vaccine
defeating
mutation when did they know about this
why have they only made this decision
and why did they originally tell the
travel industry
knowing how these variants arise that
they were going to be given three weeks
notice
well i think first of all this is
actually a mutation of the existing
therian just it's a little detail but it
sort of does matter because the who
which is the global body that decides
which are new variants it has not
formally declared there being
a new variant we should be worried about
what we actually have is a mutation of
the delta variant of cobart which is the
one that originated
in india and this has been picked up in
a couple of places around the world and
in fact with portugal
they're a victim of their own success
they've got very good genomic processing
capabilities and that means that they
saw
this phone very early on and of course
when that data was passed back to the uk
that erased alarm bells in whitehall the
other thing you've seen in portugal as
well of course
is a big uptick in number of the indian
that's the original delta valve without
the mutation
and i think really the calculation
that's gone on here is
the government is absolutely desperate
or to be more precise boris johnson
is absolutely desperate for the june the
21st easing to go ahead
and the calculation they've made is
they'd rather keep the borders tight
but allow more freedoms at home until we
get into that better
vaccinated space which logically makes
perfect sense
i can understand that and i think if you
said to most brits they would accept
that trade-off
too but then going back to what natalie
said it's the complete confusion
that the fact that we were promised that
this would not happen because we had all
this last summer with chopping and
changing with
things changing with a couple of days
notice and the government promised this
would not happen again
and it's happened again of course you
can say yes it's a pandemic
yes these things happen but the
communication i think has been pretty
poor
and there's been no real clarity about
the decision-making process with
people like me dashing around speaking
to officials trying to figure out just
what's going on today because
really nobody's none the wiser sebastian
i've got to say thank you for making
clear that variant mutation distinction
my biologist parents will be screaming
at the screen right now
natalie though i mean just just in terms
of the government communications on this
like i've interviewed countless
government ministers over the past year
and a half
and we have repeatedly put to them that
government comms have not been great
when it came to you know
hands face space all the rest of it
travel
but so this it does feel like this is
off a piece
with previous kind of government comms
issues
yeah i mean um you know the whole of the
last sort of 14 15 months has been
absolutely this complete disconnect
between what the government's saying
and what people on the ground actually
know and we've seen that really starkly
at a kind of local government level if
that's something you're looking at
i mean nottingham city council for
example when all the tier
system was announced last year in local
lockdowns there was absolute confusion
about what was happening
the government was saying one thing
there were leaks coming out left right
and center
and the communication was absolutely
horrific i think
people have sort of taken a step back
and said to themselves
well i just need to work out what i'm
going to do to keep myself safe
and you know the hands-faced space thing
there's been one message that has been
clear throughout
but people are sort of just working out
their own risks should i go abroad well
it's probably not safe at the moment
i'll stay in the uk
well well natalia then take us to the
front of the eye and the idea that you
know
we will be well many people will have to
stay in the uk
because the holiday destinations the
books are either on the red list or or
they're not letting in brits but
but the idea that the june the 21st is
this all important dates i thought we
were being guided by data
not dates well yeah exactly i mean
there's another miscommunication isn't
it but
i quite like the front of the eye i saw
this rallying call to um save the uk
holiday industry which i think is not
really a bad thing and
and so you said you went to the um
portugal i've actually booked a holiday
to the isle of wight so i'm going to be
holding up the uk holidays
and it i booked it this time last year
because i've got two young kids i need
to go on holiday in august
so i thought i need to get in there
because everyone's going to be wanting
to go to the uk
but i don't you know i don't think it's
a bad thing let's rediscover parts of
the uk
that we don't normally go to not
everyone needs to go to cornwall
blocking up that tiny road down there
let's go to you know the outer hebrides
or something
i think it is quite a good idea for once
not to go abroad and maybe rediscover
some lovely parts of the uk that people
haven't actually seen
and maybe this is a great chance to do
it yeah i mean i don't want to jinx it
now but i have my holiday boot for
scotland in august and uh
it's it's not looking precarious but you
you do worry i mean
sebastian i mean just just sticking with
it they kind of the idea of holidaying
in the uk given the government's
insistence that you should only be doing
foreign travel for you know for
essential purposes
are we also be slightly surprised that
more people have already not just
just planned their holidays for the uk
that they took the government's advice
and
and decided that you know for practical
reasons uh and for the governments
and for the government's reasons it
would have been better just to holiday
here
well i think that's definitely true now
i think we should fundamentally agree
this is not just about holidays
this is about families and britain's who
live abroad there's about 1.3 million
britons
who live in different countries across
the world who have not seen their
parents
grandparents haven't met their children
and you know i know people who have been
separated halfway across the world who
have no
prospect of seeing their nearest and
dearest people who've had to watch
zoom funerals people who have never said
goodbye to their loved ones so
when we look at this whole debate we
focus it through the lens of holidays
which
by the way are important to people
they're a very important mental break
for a lot of families across the country
it's the one thing they spend their
whole year building towards
but there is a much more emotional
element to that too and i think that
often gets lost in this debate and
people can just dismiss holidays this
frivolous thing we can all do without
which i think is certainly not true and
there is that other element to it as
well
and i think the government hasn't really
been clear enough on holidaying at home
and this really surprised me
last summer as well that there was a
stay-at-home campaign via visit britain
the uk's tourist board but
it didn't really take off and didn't
really connect with people and i don't
really understand
why the government hasn't gone more in
on this and i think you know obviously
time's running out that we're in june
now people are making their summer
holiday plans and if you've got a
family like natalie you know you've got
to decide what you're going to do during
the summer holidays
and i can imagine following today's news
the hotels the b
b's and the airbnb's will all be rather
full rather quickly
people who do want a holiday in the uk
may not have many options left and again
yes it's a pandemic yes it's all
difficult but it does just feel as if
the government could have been much
clearer if they just said
we want to get things open at home relax
lock down
that's going to make international
travel very very limited and difficult
people would have accepted that but
nobody has said that and again
i think it's this element of false hope
we had it at christmas
we had it with back in the automotive
second wave and that's what i think
makes people so frustrated
natalie just briefly because we need to
get to the bank i do want to show our
viewers that the front of the daily star
and we're not going to ask you whether
or not you agree with their assessment
of the capabilities of the people
running the country at the moment but
but there's someone who doesn't come
from a from a print or a paper's
background
do you think head to front front pages
like this are first of all are good and
do you think do you think they cut
through briefly if you can
well i mean i think the daily star has
been doing a brilliant job of its front
pages over the past year or so i think
it sort of filled the gap that the sun
seems to have left we used to get
hilarious front pages from the sun
and now we're getting them from the
daily star and we all need a bit of
light relief don't we and this is giving
us exactly that i quite like it the
daily star's got a special place in the
market and it seems to be
you know doing quite a good job of
exploiting that it's just a bit of fun
isn't it
it's um you know whether or not i agree
with the assessment or not
but um i quite like it it must have
taken quite a long time to design that
to be honest you know let's it's quite
good
and a little sneaky dom comings at the
bottom right there as well um sebastian
natalie we will pause there uh because
coming up after
the break could working from home
continue
after june the 21st we'll be discussing
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview
hopefully we have both uh sebastian
and yeah there she is she's back great
good to see you guys
um a couple of stories i think to take
ourselves through and the one we trailed
before the break
it's affecting every uh workplace there
are an awful lot of conversations
including i should say here at sky about
hybrid working
working from home just take us through
this story natalie what was the
telegraph saying
working from home is well it's going to
stay in some form surely
yeah i mean i think there's quite a few
things to sort of debate here obviously
because most firms are still
all the government's still saying to
work from home but there's this sort of
issue about what will city centres look
like in the future if there's not going
to be any office workers there
so there's that debate that needs to be
had as well what's going to be in city
centers if there's no offices
no sandwich shops no one going out at
lunch time that kind of thing
so it's a definite debate that needs to
be had about that
i mean if the government's still saying
that
we need to work from home um that
obviously causes
a lot of people problems um some people
it's not working for them
and um it's it's taken a lot of people a
lot of time to get used to
for example in the first lockdown
children were still at home
we had lots of children interrupting
zoom calls now they're back at school
it's not so bad
but i think the difficulty with how our
city centres are going to look in the
future
is something that really needs to be
thought about we're seeing that in
particular in nottingham for example
because lots of offices are still closed
um people are not in the city centers
and we've got a problem with the
shopping center in the middle of
nottingham
which was going to be a shopping centre
after the lockdown and now of course
what can it be
because there's not going to be enough
people there at lunch times to go and
shop there
and they're thinking about putting green
space in so we've got a big debate
happening about what the city centers
will look like
um sebastian i mean aside from the fact
that i booked six weeks holiday in the
first lockdown which was fantastic
believe you me
i mean i've been pretty lucky i've been
able to come into work i haven't
contracted covet as far as i'm aware
you know i haven't passed it on i'm not
sure that i could
could survive doing a job where working
from home was
the norm or even even the majority of
time
it works for some people it wouldn't
work for me and where are you
i'm a big advocate of the office as you
might guess as a kind of political
journalist it's my job to
speak to people and see people and
understand what people are saying all
the time and
during the three lockdowns you know my
world just sort of shrank to my spare
bedroom and speaking to
the same five or ten people on the
telephone every day and i'm sure
they were sick of hearing from me as i
was from hearing from them so
when it was safe and able to do so i was
able to go back into
um parliament where i work day to day
and i was delighted to do that and it's
been a great saving grace and i've seen
many of my friends in a similar
situation who've had to work from home
who found it very tedious
particularly those who live alone who
have gone you know really days without
seeing anybody and particularly
in the first lockdown before we had
those support bubbles
one thing we should be aware of this
debate about working home is very
different based on industries you know
if you in in richmond upon thames
i think 73 of people have been working
from home
in the town of burnley it's 12 percent
and that just shows you how this debate
is very much focused on
i guess sort of middle class service
sector people like you and i
who some have the options of working at
home but from a lot of the country
they don't and i think that means you've
had a very different experience
of lockdown good point well made um
natalie take us to the front of the
guardian
um politicians are demanding that the
prime minister
rethinks the the catch up for schools
but it's not the politician sitting in
front of
uh facing the prime minister it's the
one sitting behind him
yeah exactly i mean well there's there's
been a big uproar about this hasn't
there because
it's the equivalent of something like 22
pounds per head per primary school child
which is
it's just never going to help um
children catch up and
i think we've sort of touched on this in
the work from home debate you know the
pandemic has
opened up the class divide in this
country so the children
who were at home who have the luxury of
one parent being at home
who's probably might be quite
well-educated and was able to help them
had access to technology and a good
wi-fi connection
those children would have thrived or
been okay during lockdown and school
closure
but the children who maybe that both
their parents had to work out of the
home
maybe they work on the nhs front line or
as key workers
carers something like that they haven't
got access to a laptop or wi-fi
and suddenly they find they're falling a
year behind in their academic work
so it's those children that really need
the help and
perhaps the money should be redirected
towards those children in some way
um but it it just needs more money
behind it
we need teachers to probably extend the
working day it's not a popular view
extend the school day maybe keep
children in for an hour catch up if they
need to
because those sorts of skills you learn
at school you're not going to be able to
catch up on them later in life
you certainly aren't um natalie
sebastian stay
in your chairs we'll be back to you at
the top of the 11 o'clock car to
continue with our conversations